[Music]
bonjour today's video is kindly
sponsored by babel the world's number
one best-selling language learning app
hey 42 here where i come from people
like to talk about the weather
a lot
research shows that 94 of english people
have spoken about the weather at some
point in the last six hours
and almost 40 percent say they've
mentioned the weather at least once
within the last hour
that means at this very moment more than
a third of people living in england are
saying something like oh a bit warm for
this time of year isn't it or
but on a jumper david there's a nip out
but like american writer charles dudley
warner once famously said everyone's
talking about the weather but nobody's
doing anything about it
or are they
for thousands of years our species
attempted to manipulate the weather
through various high-tech methods like
rain dances and ritual sacrifices to the
gods
but at some point we were forced to
admit the truth we were running out of
virgins and livestock 2 murder and the
rainy macarena it didn't actually work
all that well
there clearly had to be better ways to
control the weather but it was only
fairly recently that we've managed to
figure out a few of them
with over 10 million subscribers
worldwide and content updated daily
babble is top of the list for anyone
who's looking to learn a new language
and it's easy to see why
i remember traveling in france and
wandering through a busy market full of
incredible produce but i couldn't
understand a single word anyone was
saying and that bothered me i really
want to unlock a greater understanding
of more languages so i can fully immerse
myself in different cultures
so i'm using babel to learn to speak
french
babel is packed full of fantastic
learning content and it's all designed
by real life language experts in order
to get you learning with real life
situations and dialogue it offers
10-minute lessons that are proven to get
you speaking in a new language in just
three weeks did you know babble also has
podcasts stories and games to completely
submerge yourself into the language of
your choice so if you're looking to
become bilingual for professional or
personal reasons or you just feel like
learning a language would be a great
achievement for you then i would highly
recommend giving babel a try
if you sign up to babel today you can
get 65
off that's less than five dollars a
month to learn a new language so click
the link in the description below au
revoir
not surprisingly the first type of
weather modification ever attempted was
the artificial creation of rain
also known as plotter culture
its origins can be traced back to the
mid 19th century and a man called james
pollard espy also known as the storm
king
with a title like that you'd be forgiven
for assuming he could conjuring with a
simple wave of his mighty hand
but somewhat disappointingly his main
climatological contribution
was nothing more than a new theory of
cloud formation
it was a pretty good theory though sb's
idea which has subsequently become an
established part of meteorology
was that storms could be caused by the
uplift of warmer air into the sky and
because he was quite a deep guy with a
punch on for overblown names he calls
this concept the philosophy of storms
based on this theory sb figured we could
create rain by starting forest fires
forcing hot air upwards to trigger cloud
formation
that idea was less of a winner but not
because it was based on flawed thinking
clouds are formed when water at the
earth's surface warms up and evaporates
the resulting water vapor rises cooling
as it does so
but water can't transition from a vapor
to a liquid without a solid surface to
attach itself to you might think the sky
doesn't seem like an obvious place to
find anything solid but it turns out
it's absolutely full of random crap just
floating around
these microscopic pieces of sky detritus
things like pollen dust particles smoke
and even bacteria act as nuclei around
which water droplets can form
once enough water condenses around these
tiny nuclei also known as cloud seeds
clouds are formed
by the way water vapor is actually
entirely clear and colorless meaning you
can't see it with the naked eye whenever
you see water vapor steam for example
what you're actually seeing are tiny
condensed water droplets anyway
if the droplets in a cloud get big
enough and heavy enough they turn into
rain or snow and fall to earth
so the storm king was actually kind of
right
we now know that the largest forest
fires which generate masses of hot air
full of moisture from burning vegetation
can indeed make clouds but it's fair to
say it isn't the most sustainable way of
making it rain
in the 1890s the us government funded
tests based on what was known as the
concussion theory of rainmaking
which i can only describe as a uniquely
american approach to the problem
bombing the clouds
the idea was that large concussive
shocks or loud noises could be used to
force clouds to release their water in
mortal fear but on this occasion the
brute force approach proved ineffective
as time went on more and more people
joined the race to come up with a
reliable method of making it rain
one australian even branded himself the
rain wizard
although he turned out to be a bit of a
damp squib well a dry squib
but you get what i mean
an american by the name of charles
hatfield was a little more convincing he
claimed to have successfully made it
rain 500 times across his career
so how did he do it
hatfield said he could attract water
with something he called the moisture
accelerator
a contraption made up of galvanized
metal evaporation tanks filled with a
secret blend of 23 chemicals
the interesting thing was it actually
seems to have worked
in fact on one occasion the device was
so effective hatfield was held
responsible for flash flooding that
caused millions of dollars worth of
damage in san diego
so how exactly did the moisture
accelerator work
sadly it almost certainly didn't most
historians agree hatfield's seemingly
impressive results had more to do with a
solid understanding of meteorology
intelligence timing
and a healthy slice of good luck
the first genuine example of weather
modification is probably cloud seeding
which began in the 1940s
in this process tiny particles of
chemicals like silver iodide potassium
iodide or dry ice are released into
clouds using planes or rockets
these microparticles act as condensation
nuclei and adding more of them increases
the chance of premature precipitation
an embarrassing event for clouds in
which they drop their rain early
slightly confusingly cloud seeding can
also be used to
prevent rain or at least prevent rain in
certain areas
during the olympics in 2008 the chinese
claims they were able to keep beijing
dry for the opening ceremony thanks to a
massive cloud seeding operation
by firing more than a thousand rockets
from 21 different locations across the
city game organizers maintain they made
menacing clouds drop their reign before
they reached the olympic stadium
scientists still disagree about the
truth of these claims but the chinese
government clearly takes it seriously
its weather modification department
employs nearly 40 000 people
the coolest of whom get to fire the 7
000 cannons and almost 5 000 rocket
launchers the program uses to seed
clouds
predictably private companies are also
getting in on the act
one travel and experience company in the
uk
offers cloud bursting services for
weddings
in exchange for a mere 100 000 pounds
they guarantee that their team of pilots
and meteorologists will deliver fair
weather and clear skies on your special
day the u.s has also been using cloud
seeding in an effort to alleviate
drought reduce the size of hailstones
and minimize fog around airports for
decades
in utah which is the second driest state
in the u.s cloud seeding is used to
build up winter snowfall over
mountainous regions to increase runoff
into rivers and streams when the snow
melts in spring and summer
in some years the state government has
said the program has delivered a 10
increase in snow
which is great
what is potentially less great is the
resulting increased concentration of
silver iodide in the water
it turns out that dumping truck loads of
silver iodide into the sky to make rain
inevitably means that some of it ends up
in the water supply though studies do
suggest that levels of silver iodide
contamination are low and well within
the environmental protection agency's
guidelines
some people are still worried though
mostly because there have been no real
studies on long-term exposure to low but
elevated levels of silver iodide
we do know that exposure to high levels
over a long period can turn your skin a
blue gray color
but they've been cloud seeding in utah
since 1973
and as yet there hasn't been a
significant rise in smurf sightings
so most people agree the practice is
safe
it's worth pointing out that it's pretty
hard to quantify exactly how well cloud
seeding actually works it can only be
done on existing clouds not clear skies
which makes it kind of challenging to
quantify its effects
after all it's hard to say for certain
that a cloud would or wouldn't have
dropped its rain without a solid
peppering of silver iodide
so the scientific jury is still out to
lunch on the question of whether cloud
seeding actually works
which means it's probably worth keeping
our eyes open for other ways to make the
world a wetter place and flab tests
suggest that trillion watt lasers
might be one promising option
pulsating infrared lasers make clouds by
stripping electrons from the atoms in
the air
creating ions that act as seeds to grow
clouds
so far most of the research has been
done in labs and on a small scale
but researchers have successfully
managed to create at least one cloud on
demand in the skies above germany
just before they broke into a fistfight
over whether it looked like a dragon or
mickey mouse
in dubai they use drones to zap clouds
of electricity which apparently
increases the size of any subsequent
raindrops that's important because it's
so hot there that smaller raindrops
evaporate before they even hit the
ground in the broader united arab
emirates there are plans to build
man-made mountains that will help create
clouds by forcing air to rise and
condense
critics say that's a bad idea because
mountains create rain shadows which
means the area on one side of the
mountain gets loads of rain whilst the
other side hardly gets any but that's
just an issue with rain making in
general
whilst we're busy exploring all the
different ways we could make it rain
the question we've been avoiding dr ian
malcolm's style
is whether we should
after all the methods we've discussed so
far don't create water out of nothing
they simply alter where that rain falls
and that's a pretty important
distinction for every dry wedding
there's a flooded campsite up the road
for every dry area receiving
artificially created rain there's an
even drier area over the rise that's
been rubbed of precious water
there's only so much water vapor in the
air to go around and every time we
create a cloud or make it rain
we're using it up
that means that countries or even
individuals who have the technology and
money
can wield some pretty awesome power
over our planet's water supply
and that's just talking about rain
scientists are now looking at techniques
for geoengineering weather on a much
larger scale hoping to find last ditch
options for avoiding a climate disaster
one company is looking at using an 18
mile long hose held up by helium
balloons to pump large quantities of
sulfur dust into the earth's atmosphere
in order to reflect the sun's rays and
cool down the earth
that might sound kind of ridiculous but
it's worked in the past or at least the
principal has
during massive volcanic eruptions large
quantities of material are released into
the air traveling high into the
atmosphere and spreading out across the
planet in high enough concentrations
these particles can block out the sun
causing global dimming and major
temperature drops
as you'll know if you've seen my video
on volcanoes we saw exactly this after
the eruption of mount tambora in
indonesia in 1815
the biggest volcanic eruption in
recorded history that released around
200 cubic kilometers of material into
the atmosphere
1816 the year after the event became
known as the year without a summer as
global average temperatures dropped by
around half a degree
which might not sound like a lot but
summer temperatures in europe were the
coldest on record leading to major food
shortages across the entire northern
hemisphere
part of this effect was caused by
high-altitude sulfate aerosols
small droplets of sulfuric acid and
water that reflects sunlight back into
space
as in the example i just mentioned
scientists are looking at various ways
we might mimic this process to slow down
climate change if you're thinking wait a
minute
didn't they tell us to stop using
aerosols to save the ozone layer then
you're on to one of the biggest problems
facing this approach whilst doing a good
job of cooling the planet down sulfate
aerosols would also be pretty bad for
the ozone layer the atmosphere and
life in general so
yeah there's that
weather and climate are extremely
complex systems and the truth is nobody
really knows what will happen when we
start messing about with it on a large
scale
a change in one place could trigger a
domino effect that leads to
unpredictable consequences somewhere
else
and as we're already seeing playing with
the world's thermostat
is generally not a great idea which is
exactly why geoengineering makes a lot
of people very nervous
to put so much power into a few people's
hands
could be very dangerous
there are no laws to regulate
geoengineering itself and every country
has sovereignty over its own airspace so
no one can tell a government what
they're allowed to fire into their sky
so things could go really wrong if
countries or individuals take it upon
themselves to start fiddling with the
weather
and yes there are even concerns these
technologies could be weaponized
many people chuckled in 2018
when the head of iran's civil defense
organization accused israel of stealing
iran's clouds and rain
but the idea of using weather
modification as a weapon has been around
for a long time
way back in 1976 the un general assembly
passed the environmental modification
convention which banned weather warfare
unsurprisingly conspiracy theories in
this area are as plentiful as cloud
seeds there are the old rumors like the
one about the cia using rain making to
flood the viet cong out of the jungle
during the vietnam war
but more recent favorites focus on
chemtrails and harp
if you've ever looked up at the sky and
noticed those pretty streaks left behind
aeroplanes flying at high altitudes
you'll know what contrails are short for
condensation trails contrails form when
warm moist exhaust fumes from an
aircraft mix with the cold air around
them and produce clouds of ice crystals
the chemtrails theory suggests that
those are not clouds of condensation but
rather clouds of chemicals being
released into the atmosphere to control
the weather climate and because this is
a conspiracy theory and therefore needs
to be a bit more headline grabby
our minds
as for harp it has nothing to do with
angels or music it stands for high
frequency active auroral research
program
this network of 360 radio transmitters
180 antennas and five powerful
generators
nestled in the alaskan wilderness was
created to study the ionosphere the
highest part of the earth's atmosphere
that starts around 48 kilometers up
concerned citizens though believe this
particular harp might be playing a more
nefarious tune the organization has been
accused of causing earthquakes cyclones
flooding snowstorms and other disasters
as well as other general naughtiness
like attacking the people of the world
telepathically weather control is very
much a young science but technology in
this space is progressing rapidly and
soon enough
it will have the power to change the
world as we know it
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing
only time will tell
thank you for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us it's a wild and
witty journey for a thousand years of
unexpected
roman history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in
thank you